ils ont 13 et 14 ans on est là comme
ignorance des gouvernements face à la
crise climatique même sont une
démocratie représentative
le peuple
pouvoir antonin gérard esnault a du
charme se rendent devant l'assemblée
nationale pour manifester
presque tous les jeudis 16h15 depuis le
mois de février leur initiative attire
de plus en plus de leurs camarades et
fou qu'il ose vous qu'il imagine le
monde d'une autre façon j'étais en
octobre et c'est une grande source
d'inspiration leur rendez vous
hebdomadaire rappelle celui lancé par la
jeune militante écologiste à 15 ans
grete attenberg protestaient devant le
parlement suédois chaque vendredi pour
les mêmes raisons un mouvement
international s'en est suivi
des millions de jeunes aux quatre coins
de la planète ont protesté à ses côtés
notamment à montréal pour presser les
gouvernements à agir face à la crise
climatique
noah et antonin ont participé à
l'organisation de la marche du 24
septembre dernier à québec
le futur ce qui s'en vient je peux être
trop alarmiste mais c'est la fin
l'humanité parce que conviant tous les
cataclysmes climatiques sont en train
d'arriver les cordeurs de sécheresse la
fonte du pergélisol
des gouvernements qui tourne le dos aux
açores entonnant se dit éco anxieux et
les loin d'être le seul de plus en plus
de jeunes le sont selon une étude
validée par le journal scientifique de
l'inde 7 45% des jeunes de 16 à 25 ans
sondées dans 10 pays affirme que les
couacs cité affectent leur vie
quotidienne
59 % se déclarent très ou extrêmement
inquiet on exige un changement on est
prêts à des actions mais prêt à faire
quelque chose si ça change pas si c'est
pas vous qui l'en qui fait avancer
changement volcan il ya quelqu'un qui
veulent faire à votre place les jeunes
militants ont beau être peu nombreux
issop la classe alla anodin comme ça
mais ça peut avoir un impact il rappelle
que toute révolution a commencé quelque
part ici marie pierre mercier radio
canada québec